if you look at this chart here if you
can pull it up Eric so the audience can
see it this this kind of shows you uh
employee donations to midterms uh
candidates by party okay blue being
Democrat red being Republican look at
Netflix
99.6 of the donations was to the
Democratic party only point four percent
was to the Republican Party obviously
they're not biased at all at Twitter was
98.7 at Airbnb is 98 Apple 97.5 stripe
97 left 96 Google alphabet 96 Salesforce
95 Facebook 95 Tesla 94 eBay 93 PayPal
92 Microsoft 92 Amazon 89 Uber 81 healed
that Packard 80 Intel 78 look at Oracle
time at the bottom with you know Larry
Ellison it's like look man fourth or
fifth richest man he was on the
billionaire list a minute ago we had on
the donors 66 here 33.9 I think uh a a
big part of this the reason why I'm
showing this is because if if you are
trying to use social media and you're
telling me there is no bias that the
people that are working at some of these
companies it's a lie and you got 99 that
are only going one side I I feel bad for
the point four percent Republican that
works at Netflix think about how they
view that person it's kind of like look
uh can we get like five Republican
employees here just to kind of even
things out so they don't say we're fully
Democrat just so we can always use those
three guys or five guys but what do you
think about when you see numbers like
this Tom
uh well I look at where most of these
were headquartered
um Silicon Valley and well Microsoft up
there in Washington you know the land of
the Birkenstock so I I think you you've
got that and you also have an emerging
generation that's part of this and I I I
think there's a lot of leadership that
thinks you have to be on the right side
of History because I don't believe these
donations necessarily reflect the true
playing field
um that's out there I don't think it
represents their customer sets and you
know it's also very very interesting a
lot of these companies and there's a
couple of them in there they have
policies about what you don't talk to
your customer about so we may be giving
it this way but when we talk to our
customers I know it's this way at
salesforce.com it's like our customers
are going to be from both sides of the
aisle our customers are going to have
all kinds of viewpoints and we can't
bring our personal political views and
offend our customers because if you look
at the statistics according to the
election it's what 48.5 of the United
States is on the other side so not one
of these folks is going to want to give
up 48.5 percent of their customers so
how they are in their hearts and in
their personal views is not how they
necessarily behave in front of their
customers although there's companies
like apple that are you know definitely
way out there in very open and
Progressive publicly Adam what do you
think about when you see this I think
this is actually a very very powerful
stat right here because these companies
I mean down the list these are the
companies running America running the
world for that matter okay and
you know when you talk about cancel
culture
um here's a reason why these are all the
platforms like when we sat down with
Andrew Tate not only did it get banned
from Twitter and YouTube and Facebook
and meta and Instagram and Discord then
it happened to be PayPal and stripe next
it was Uber and Lyft and I kind of joke
do you think that all these Silicon
Valley guys are on a text message
together just kind of like how we're on
a text message with buddies and the
answer is yeah of course they're kind of
there's a group think mentality the
problem is
these are the people running America but
this is not representative of what
America is let's use an example of Jimmy
Kimmel the other day like Jimmy Kimmel
has lost half his audience yep because
he's completely done and by the way the
same thing for uh Colbert to a lesser
extent Fallon
um what's the other guy Seth Meyers
they've doubled down on their hate for
Trump not a chemical level though
camel I think are at the same level I
think Fallon is like you know a little
less political but that's my point yeah
is that just because you have a certain
ideology or a certain business model
doesn't mean you should alienate the
other half of America
right so I think it's a poor business
model but it is a a Telltale sign of why
certain people get canceled right or why
certain types of content gets a strike
because look at the people running these
companies it's a very powerful message
here well you said it one time pat
remember when you talked about who was
the most the most five more most
powerful is it the government the
President social media and business I
think universities universities yeah you
made you you talked about this and
mainstream media and mainstream media
and I think this is showing a lot going
back to that point when you talked about
that by the way can you pull up the
concept of capitalism versus corporatism
pull up the difference between
capitalism versus corporatism just put
difference between capitalism and
corporatism and then zoom in okay if you
if you zoom in here if you zoom in right
there for the definition so we can see
it capitalism is an economic system that
recognizes individual rights while
corporatism is a political and economic
system that seeks social justice and
equal quality among individuals right so
when you look at a the model of how much
money they're putting into the left or
the right and you're seeing the amount
of power that they have you're seeing an
example of corporatism here where the
the here's Netflix that dictates what
content your kids watch they're putting
99.6 onto one side here's Facebook
that's dictating how many people get
your viewership they're putting their
money on one side not only that you know
Zuck is another you know however much
money he put into it I think it's a
interesting thing when you see that data
by the way if there's another one of
these companies that somebody from the
right like an Elon Musk can come out of
nowhere and buy who would that be if
there's a company that can be bought by
somebody on the right at a discount at
this point it's Facebook are you kidding
me how much money they've lost over the
last 12 months snap
you thinking snap
you're thinking he brings something to
do like a tick tock thing right if
you're talking about something that's
depressed they're down 92 percent their
stock price is down 92 which means that
they're
the ability to buy them the price is
down 92 percent I don't know that it's a
very good platform but that's a social
that is a troubled highly discounted
social media platform that someone could
pick up if they thought they could do
better
yeah
hundreds of millions of years what about
these other platforms that have shown up
the rumbles of the world the parlors of
the world what is it tumblr what are
these other things uh whether it's truth
social do these things have a place in
in mainstream media not not parlor
because it's tied to Kanye that that
thing is done done for now that's going
to take a time out for a minute I think
Rumble for sure they're not going away
now they're getting bigger and bigger uh
they had a chance to put Rumble out of
business a few years ago they didn't do
it it's backfiring on them because
Rumble is taking market share and
they're raising money left and right and
they're picking people up they come and
create content with us Russell Brand is
now making content on Rumble you're
getting all these names that are not
moving and they're taking market share
away from YouTube from of course YouTube
from from a lot of different places
they're taking market share alphabet
yeah alphabet and and and that's going
to continue to happen but I'm talking
about who has the funds that when you
look at these numbers I'm talking about
these big boys okay these companies
these numbers that Netflix Twitter so
Twitter's now musk Airbnb apple and no
one's going to buy apple apple is a at
this point it's a country of its own
stripe lift Google Salesforce Facebook
you know these are influential companies
you know and who even has that kind of
money to go buy some of these guys it's
going to be interesting because Twitter
being bought by Elon Musk was probably
one of the best things that happened but
will any of these other guys go for sell
I don't know we're gonna see what's
going to happen here toward your future
looks bright hat click over here and to
watch the entire podcast click here take
care everybody
foreign
[Music]